كشف تسريب غير مسبوق
لوثائق صينية داخلية إلى CNN
لأول مرة عما
عرفته الصين في الأسابيع الأولى
لوباء كوفيت 19 ،
لكنها لم تخبر العالم
عن مخالفات قالت إنهم عملوا
داخل نظام الرعاية الصحية الصيني
وشاركوا الوثائق مع شبكة سي إن إن عبر الإنترنت
والتي  أظهر
رد فعل محلي فوضوي منذ البداية
هذا النقص في الشفافية
نوعًا ما ساهم أيضًا في أزمة
رؤية
المعلومات أه بالأبيض والأسود أه كانت
كاشفة للغاية ومفيدة قامت CNN
بالتحقق منها مع نصف دزينة من الخبراء
، مسؤول أمني أوروبي وباستخدام
الطب الشرعي الرقمي المعقد  التحليل الذي
يبحث في الكود المصدري الخاص بهم ،
توفر الوثائق عددًا من
الاكتشافات الرئيسية حول مقاطعة هوبي ،
موطن مدينة ووهان ،
أولاً ، كانت بعض أعداد القتلى
في أسوأ يوم
في هذه التقارير في السابع عشر من فبراير
حيث قالوا إن
196 شخصًا  تم التأكد من وفاة الحالات
ولكن في ذلك اليوم أعلنوا عن 93 حالة فقط.
كما كانت الصين تنتشر داخليًا
ب  igger مجاميع أكثر تفصيلاً
للحالات الجديدة في هوبي ليوم واحد في
فبراير مسجلة داخليًا
ما يقرب من 6000 حالة جديدة تم تشخيص بعضها عن طريق
اختبارات
أخرى سريريًا من قبل الأطباء والبعض
يشتبه بسبب الأعراض
والمخالطة ولكن جميعها خطيرة جدًا
ولكن علنًا في ذلك اليوم أبلغت الصين عن
حوالي 2500 حالة على الصعيد الوطني  الحالات المؤكدة الجديدة
تم التقليل من شأن البقية في
إحصاء مستمر للحالات المشتبه فيها
مما يعني الصبر على تشخيص الأطباء على
أنهم مرضى بشكل
خطير كما لو كانوا في حالة شك ، لكنه
حسّن لاحقًا المعايير
إذا كانت الصين أكثر شفافية وأكثر
عدوانية في الاستجابة بوضوح
كان من الممكن أن يكون له تأثير على
مدى انتشار الفيروس في ووهان في
هوبي
في الصين وربما إلى بقية
العالم ، كما
تكشف الوثائق
سببًا محتملاً وراء التناقض
في الأرقام
، حيث أفاد تقرير من أوائل مارس أن الأمر استغرق
مذهل 23 يومًا في المتوسط
لوقت الذي أظهر فيه شخص ما أعراضًا سرية 19 إل
عندما حصل على تأكيد  التشخيص الطبي
الذي يستغرق ثلاثة أسابيع للقبض على كل حالة رسميًا ،
يبدو أن هذه المعلومات
مفاجئة جدًا بالنسبة لي
لأنه عادةً ما يستغرق الأمر
بضعة أيام فقط ، فأنت تضع السياسة
اليوم
بناءً على المعلومات التي
مضى عليها ثلاثة أسابيع
وربما تكون الأكثر روعة  كان الوحي
قلقًا في أوائل
ديسمبر في اللحظة التي ظهرت فيها 19 سرية لأول مرة
في الصين
وبدأت هذه الوثائق تكشف
عن ارتفاع هائل
في حالات الإنفلونزا في هوبرت تمامًا
عندما أظهرت الدراسات
أن أول مرضى معروفين
أصيبوا بـ
19 ضعف عدد حالات الإنفلونزا
مقارنة
إلى الأسبوع نفسه من العام السابق
قال الخبراء إنه كان من الممكن أن يغمر نظام المستشفى
بالمرضى المصابين بأعراض شبيهة
بالإنفلونزا
مما يجعل من الصعب اكتشاف الحالات الأولى
لـ covid19.
تم
فحص المرضى بانتظام
ولم يكن لدى الكثير منهم سلالة معروفة من فيروس الأنفلونزا
مما يترك الاحتمال مفتوحًا  لقد كانوا
مرضى بالطمع 19.
كان الارتفاع في ووهانغ
حقًا غير معتاد مقارنةً بـ
eos السابقة التي تعرفها ، وكان ذلك من شأنه أن يرفع
العلم الأحمر ، وكان
من الواضح جدًا أن علماء الفيروسات الصينيين
يمكنهم إجراء
تشخيصات دقيقة للأنفلونزا ولكن في
وقت لاحق  يجب أن نتساءل هل
كان هناك بعض الطمع
متنكرا في زي
الإنفلونزا ، تظهر الوثائق أيضًا أن تفشي الإنفلونزا
كان الأكبر في الأسبوع الأول من ديسمبر
ليس في ووهان ولكن في مدينتين أخريين
قريبتين في هوبي ،
كل المعلومات القيمة في البحث عن
المكان الذي جاء فيه المرض من
الصين  قال المسؤولون إن تفشي المرض
بدأ هنا في سوق هوانان للمأكولات البحرية في
ووهان في منتصف ديسمبر
، وعلى الرغم من الاتهامات الغربية
بأنها حدت من تعاونها مع الذين
يحققون في أصول الفيروس ،
أصرت الصين على أنها كانت
شفافة قدر الإمكان فيما
يتعلق بفيروس كورونا بالنسبة للبعض.  حان الوقت الآن
من أجل تحويل اللوم ، قالت إن
بعض السياسيين الأمريكيين
استخدموا الوباء باستمرار وآخرون  يقاضي كذريعة لتشويه وشيطنة الصين والأكاذيب والمعلومات المضللة عن الصين ، وهذا بالطبع سيضلل بشكل خطير مواطني الولايات المتحدة وبعض الدول الغربية الأخرى فهم حقيقة حرب الصين ضد الوباء وزارة الخارجية الصينية ومسؤولي الصحة في بكين ووهان لم يستجب لطلباتنا للتعليق على هذا المرض قتل ما يقرب من مليون ونصف المليون شخص حوالي خمس الوفيات المعروفة في أمريكا.هذه الوثائق نادرة وواضحة نافذة مفتوحة لما كانت الصين تعرفه طوال الوقت تحاول الظهور بمظهر السيطرة بينما تحول الفاشية المحلية إلى جائحة عالمي نيك بايتون والش CNN لندن